Oprah, Beyonce and Gaga are just a few of the high-powered women...
...to make it on Forbes' newest prestigious list.
Oprah holds steady at number 14 on the tally...
...marking the 10th anniversary of Forbes' annual list of the World's Most Powerful Women.
You may think Oprah would be higher,...
...but it's ranked by money, media momentum and social impact.
Michelle Obama came in at number 8, Melinda Gates comes in at number 3...
...and Hillary Clinton is number 6.
As for the celebs, Angelina Jolie, who serves as a special envoy...
...for the UN High Commissioner for Refugees, nabbed number 50.
Sofia Vergara came in at 32, Shakira came in at 58,...
...Gaga at 67 and Ellen DeGeneres came in at 46.
But those ladies are no match for Beyonce, who impressively came in at number 17.